- [Instructor] This
polynomial division business
is a little bit more fun than we expected.
So let's keep going.
So let's say that, I guess again,
someone walks up to you in the street
and says "What is x squared
plus one divided by x plus two."
So pause this video and have a go at that.
And I'll give you a
little bit of a warning.
This one's a little bit more
involved than you might expect.
All right, so there's two
ways to approach this.
Either we can try to
re-express the numerator
where it involves an x plus two somehow,
or we could try to do
algebraic long division.
So let me do the first way.
So x squared plus one,
it's not obvious that
you can factor it out.
But can you write something
that has x plus two as a factor,
and interestingly enough
has no first degree terms?
'Cause we don't want
some first degree weird
first degree terms sitting up there.
And the best thing that
I could think of is,
constructing a different of
squares using x plus two.
So we know that x plus two
times x minus two is equal to
x squared minus four.
So what is we were to write
x squared minus four up here,
and then we would just have to
add five to get to plus one.
So what if we were to
write x squared minus four
and then we write plus five.
This expression and that
expression up there,
those are completely equivalent.
But why did I do that?
Well, now I can write
x squared minus four as
x plus two times x minus two.
And so then I could rewrite
this entire expression
as x plus two times x
minus two, all of that over
x plus two plus five,
plus five over x plus two.
And now as long as x does
not equal negative two,
then we could divide the
numerator and the denominator
by x plus two.
And then we would be left
with x minus two plus five
over x plus two, and I'll
put that little constraint,
if I wanna say that this
expression is the same as that
first expression, for x does not equal,
for x not equaling negative two.
And so here, we'd say "Hey!
X squared plus one divided by
x plus two is x minus two,"
and then we have a remainder
of five, remainder of five.
Now let's do the same question,
or try to rewrite this
using algebraic long division.
We'll see that this is actually a
little bit more straightforward.
So we are going to divide
x plus two into x squared
plus one.
Now when I write things out I
like to be very careful with
my, I guess you could say,
with my different places
for the different degrees.
So x squared plus one
has no first degree term,
so I'm gonna write the one out here.
So second degree, no first
degree term, and then
we have a one, which is
a zero degree term, or constant term.
And so, we do the same
drill, how many times does
x go into x squared.
We're just looking at the
highest degree terms here.
X goes into x squared x
times, that's first degree
so I put it in the first degree column.
X times two is two x.
X times x is x squared.
And now we wanna subtract.
And so what is this gonna be equal to?
We know the x squared's cancel out.
And then I'm gonna be
subtracting negative two x
from, you could do this
as plus zero x up here
plus one, and so you're
left with negative two x.
And then we bring down that one plus one.
X goes into negative two
x, negative two times.
Put that in the constant column.
Negative two times two is negative four.
And then negative two
times x is negative two x.
Now we have to be very
careful here because we want
to subtract the negative
two x minus four from
the negative two x plus one.
We could view it as this
or we could just distribute
the negative sign.
And then this will be
positive two x plus four.
And then, the two x's, the two x
and the negative two x cancels out.
One plus four is five and
there's no obvious way
of dividing x plus two
into five so we would call
that the remainder,
exactly what we had before.
When we divided with
algebraic long division,
we got x minus two, x minus
two with a remainder of five.